طيب تعرفيني عن نرمين صباح الخير
صباح الخير انا هنا معايا القصه الكبيره
قوي
نرمين ناجح وزوجها احنا في ورشه برده
زوجها الاستاذ عاطف ايه دخلت مهنه رجالي
جدا بس هي دخلتها لانها حباها ومميزه فيها
وبقت لها زباين كثير بيطلبوها بالاسم صباح
الخير ازيك حضرتك
حبيت المجال حبيت الفكره شغل الدهانات
حبيت ان حاجه تبقى متبهدله ومكسره وتيجي
في شوال تلاقيها حاجه بقت قيمه فحابه
الفكره بس مش اكتر بداتي من امتى بقى لي
الساعه 12 سنه اه 20 سنه
كمان همم
استر ودوكو ولاكيه وشغله الاساسات يعني
شغلتي الاساسيه ايه اه اه بس الورشه جانب
النقاشه ان انا ما بقدرش
اتحرك كثير مع المدارس بتاع الاولاد في
المدرسه لكن انت بالنسبه لك انت لما بداتي
ملقتيش معارضه من الاسره من الاهل من
بافكر ما حدش قال لك ايه الشغلانه اللي
انت داخلاها دي بتاعه رجاله لا لا بالعكس
هم ادوني دعم كامل و بيهتموا بالاولاد
وانا في شغل نقاشه بره لان ممكن انا واثق
بنقعد بالايام بره بنبقى شغالين في في
بلاد في اماكن بعيده
فلا في ناس بتطلبك يعني هل بالاسم يعني في
مثلا ممكن تبقى ستات قاعده لوحدها ستات
كثيره جدا
وفرحانين في فكره
عندهم فكره ان همم
ان ان ما بقاش في اللي هو لازم يبقى راجل
متواجد في البيت عشان خاطر
ان ان ان صنايعي راجل طالع فاشلت الحاجز
اه الحاجز اللي هو بتاع ان ست طالع خلاص
الموضوع منتهي مش لازم راجل يعني موجود
انا عايزه كمان اروح للاستاذ عاطف استاذ
عاطف انت لما مراتك قالت لك انا هادخل معك
انت ده من اول ما اتجوزته مش كده
تحب تبص للحاجه تسال همم ابتدت من كده
يعني واحنا مخطوبين اصلا
بس هي ابتدات تشتغل لما اتجوزت وانت
معترضتش
لان انا شايف ان هي يعني يجي منها يعني
حبه شاطره يعني
يعني بتعمل حاجه يعني خلاص شايفه انها جزء
فني مش موضوع حاجه يدوي او صانعه بس يعني
عندها حس فني معين يعني
تمام النهارده استضافتنا الاستاذ نرمين
وهمم الحقيقه انا عرفت انها برده معلومه
هي بدات تتدرب كونغ فو علشان لو رايحه
مكان قلقانه منه صح يا نرمين صح ابتدتها
في الشروق في الرحاب في المناطق الانشائيه
الجديده بس ست معينه لازم لوحدي فما ينفعش
جوزي مثلا يبقى معاه
عملت اخذت حمايه بس لنفس يعني
تمام تمام شكرا لكم جدا واا بشكر
زوجها وانا بشكركم جدا وباشكر قناه
العربيه وشرفتوني ربنا يخليك ميرسي يا
حبيبتي شكرا
يا سمر
ههه
شكرا جزيلا سمر